Speaker 1: Ron DeSantis had a book event and
he had all the Trump supporters kicked out.
Is this free speech? Is this inclusiveness?
Is this a big tent party? This is one of my
absolute favorite things this week. Extremist
Laura Loomer, who I think very little of.
She went with a bunch of Trump
people to a DeSantis event
in Leesburg, Florida. It was a book event,
Books-a-million. And the Trump people were kicked
out by security because the DeSantis people said
they've got to go. Now, remember, DeSantis isn't
even running. Trump's not DeSantis, his opponent
in any official sense right now. And in addition
to that, Trump did endorse DeSantis for governor,
albeit pretty halfheartedly. So it's wild that
this is going on. Take a look at this video of
security telling Laura Loomer and all of the Trump
people, the DeSantis people, are kicking you out.
Unidentified: And they went along with it. Yes.
Why? Because. Because of what you when they told.
Speaker 4: Me to say anything I want. Trump has
to go right now.
Speaker 1: Oh,
I mean, listen, all these people are nuts.
But anybody wearing Trump has to go right
now is whacked stuff already made. This isn't
like, you know, if you try to go to a if Ron
DeSantis declares that he's running and a bunch of
people try to get into the rally with Trump signs,
obviously they're going to take the Trump
signs and probably kick you out. That's a
political rally. This is not a political
rally. This is a very different thing.
And they're still kicking these people out.
Speaker 4: Be on time. I'm sorry, guys. I have to.
Speaker 1: Call it up now. Okay. He's got to
call the police now. And then there's another
clip here where the security guy even seems to say
to these folks, you're acting like the far left.
It's crazy what is happening. But the big story is
Trump supporters kicked out. DeSantis doesn't want
Trump supporters there. Here we go.
Speaker 4: Oh.
Speaker 1: Oh, boy. Looks like our clip froze
here. Let's see if we can reset here and get
it going, because this is a critical clip.
Speaker 4: Are you acting like the far left?
Because we're acting like the far left, trying to
get Trump elected? Yeah, well, you're acting like
the far left. You're like a Trump elected.
Speaker 1: Brilliant security guard.
Speaker 4: The same way trying to get Trump
elected, Trying to get Trump elected is the far
left. Yes. Trying to get Trump elected is the far
left. Listen, I am a Trump supporter. Technically,
technically, you shouldn't be over there.
Then I'm doing my job. I mean, so are we.
Speaker 1: Are we? How crazy is this American
right wing movement? Just people. Everybody's
brain is just has been replaced with mayonnaise.
Speaker 4: But you're one part private
property. You need to leave. Okay.
Speaker 5: Sorry to hear what he said.
He said that people told them that anybody who's
wearing a Trump hat for anything, anything Trump,
they have to leave. So where you know,
Governor DeSantis likes to pretend like
he's a governor and favor free speech. Yeah,
he talks a big talk, but really, he allows
for elections to be stolen by big talk. And now.
Speaker 1: All right. Anyway, so going into those
criticisms and then here's one more clip of the
same. Listen, guy. The security guard supports
Trump, but he's just doing his job.
Speaker 4: The his people are
in there seeing me come out to
tell you guys not to be here.
Speaker 1: Why he's here.
Speaker 4: Signing for the.
Speaker 5: Governor. This answers why It's like
like he always talks about how he's in favor of
free speech, Like we have a First Amendment right
to be here to rally in support of President Trump.
Speaker 1: Right?
Speaker 5: You do.
Right. So not now.
Speaker 4: That's
so great. You do have that right.
Speaker 1: But I'm suspending that right
as regards to this parking lot while Ron DeSantis
is in there signing, signing books. Oh, my God,
this is going to be an insane primary. So not
exactly for, I guess, the speech of these people
out in the parking lot, even not even inside the
event. DeSantis just doesn't want to see them.
And this is I get it. DeSantis wants the book
signing to be about him rather than about Trump.
But when Trump is supposedly a political ally
who endorsed you and whose support you welcomed,
then all of this stuff, kicking all of these
people out is pretty wild. So we'll have all
of these clips on our Instagram. You can search
Instagram for David Pakman show. And if you're
interested in getting these clips in Spanish
for your Spanish speaking friends and relatives,
go to David Pakman dot com slash Spanish. Make
sure you're subscribed to the Spanish channel.